we got some truly crazy reveals and a
flashback that includes not only Kuma
Bonnie Vega Punk and Saturn but kizaru
Dragon Ace mihawk the other Warlords
even Luffy and more Oda saved something
truly special for chapter 1,100 as we
expected so make sure to stay tuned for
this one sh P King within and smash that
like button if you enjoy one piece
reviews like this one I want to keep
them coming make this the video you join
the Naka by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece reviews and updates by hitting
that virtual button you are helping me
achieve my dream of reaching 2 million
subscribers here on YouTube and now
without further Ado let's jump into this
crazy chapter that among other things
really shows how far key characters like
Luffy and Kobe have come since the story
began this chapter is called thank you
Bonnie so we're still on the crazy
backstory and life of poor Kuma and
Bonnie although they aren't the most
popular characters in the fan base Oda
has definitely delivered on their
backstories kumas must be one of the
darkest we've seen if not the darkest
but it ain't even over yet as we're
about to get into PS let me know if you
can think of a darker one piece
backstory in the comments so this
chapter starts where the last one ended
where if you'll remember Kuma and Bonnie
were on ha head with Vega Punk and
sanomaru Vega Punk had just told Kuma
that he can save Bonnie and in turn
he'll just need to use Kuma's Buccaneer
blood as the foundation for his
pacifista clones these clones as VGA
Punk intended were supposed to be a
force for good for Fighting Evil Pirates
and being shields for the innocent of
course we know things don't quite work
out like that and it's because Saturn
the Elder on Egghead right now who
Bonnie blames for all of this was
listening to the conversation with a spy
snail he has his own ideas for using
Kuma as we'll get into soon here we see
that kizaru visits Vega Punk's
laboratory submarines like Drake were
following him that's a cool touch as
well Drake is definitely one of the
cooler Marines it's also made clear that
Vega Punk didn't know about the Spy
snails or spy denen Mushi inside the lab
because he had just moved into this
building after the accident in Punk
Hazard so yes as we know by now and even
as Dragon you meega punk is a good guy
the government just loves using him for
their evil ends kizaru brings Saturn's
denan Mushi because he wants to talk
with Vega Punk Saturn also said he's
aware of Vega Punk's illegal
negotiations with a pirate meeing Kuma
however since Kuma will make an
excellent host for the Clone Army Saturn
decides to allow the deal of course he
adds three conditions that will not turn
out so well as we know one Kuma must be
a warlord replacing an unnamed warlord
who was defeated by Ace a few days ago
on a side note that's a cool detail I
always enjoy learning more about Ace and
the fact that he just took down a
warlord is awesome would love to see
that fight ACE also fought warlord jimbe
for 5 days until they both collapsed
from exhaustion and warlord Blackbeard
although we know he lost that one either
way he seemed to love battling Warlords
number two Kuma must become a Human
Weapon undergoing a cyborg surgery
number three Kuma's mind must be erased
when his surgery ends ends all of these
conditions are what leads to the present
where so far instead of a happy ending a
seemingly mindless Kuma is being abused
by Celestial dragons hopefully they
somehow find a way to return his
memories after all we saw that Bonnie
has already had access to them through
one of Kuma's paw bubbles but Vega Punk
being the good guy that he is is furious
with these conditions as he says wiping
a Cyborg's brain is the same as killing
the man while Saturn for his part gives
him a reality check saying he's in no
position to argue with the Elder and
calls him a marine scientist in a
derogatory way still for Kuma's part he
actually cries tears of joy because he
will finally be able to save Bonnie he
is such a good guy and OD shows that
again I'm just liking him more and more
with every chapter at this point #
Justice foruma it makes sense that he'd
react this way too because as he said
last chapter he'd even make a deal with
the devil if it meant saving Bonnie and
with Saturn's recent demonic form
revealed that didn't end up being far
from the truth so Vega Punk then
explains that Bonnie's surgery will take
6 months and after that she must rest
for one year before she can go outside
on the other hand Kuma surgery will take
2 years Saturn says Bonnie will be their
hostage if Bonnie is cured there's a
risk that Kuma may run away with her so
after her 6month treatment Bonnie must
be in World Government custody for one
year the government promises to release
her after regap Punk erases Kuma's mind
but man I would never believe these guys
at this point they are just evil what's
more to prevent them from running away
together Kuma won't be allowed to meet
Bonnie ever again after her six-month
treatment tragic stuff but nothing new
for Kuma and in fact since she'll be
cured for Kuma even this tragic
condition doesn't take away from his
happiness so that pretty much means even
if Bonnie doesn't know it these 6 months
will be their last 6 months together
Kuma will have to make the most of them
Kuma of course agrees to Saturn's
conditions but in exchange asks for them
to send Bonnie to sorb Kingdom after the
six-month treatment to prevent her from
knowing the truth about this deal Saturn
agrees since as long as she is under the
world government's eyes anywhere is the
same for them got to say this backstory
is doing a great job of fleshing out all
of the significance of all of the non
Straw Hat characters on Egghead right
now even Saturn as the big evil bad guy
of this Arc I can't wait to see him
defeated after all this evil stuff he
did his defeat will be so cathartic for
everyone especially for Bonnie and I
can't wait to see it and since Oda is
spending so much time explaining all of
this stuff about how evil Saturn is and
all the terrible things he did it makes
me strongly believe that Saturn will
face defeat sooner rather than later
after the deal between Kuma and Saturn
we see a montage of Kuma Bonnie Vega
Punk and sentomaru spending time
together and growing closer to one
another during these six months knowing
all of this it's completely
understandable why Vega Punk was so
protective over Bonnie in recent
chapters and even kizaru is shown to be
very close to them too we see him
joining a pizza party and even dancing
with them as I've been pointing out this
Arc kizaru has repeatedly been saying
that he doesn't want to fight sentomaru
or Bonnie but only does so when they get
in the way of his mission this backstory
better explains why he really doesn't
want to fight them and this is coming to
a boiling point this Arc I'm telling you
guys we're going to get some big stuff
from kizaru whether it's him finally not
putting the mission first for once or
whether it's us finally figuring out why
he is so obsessed with following orders
and missions even if it means attacking
his friends there is a reason Oda called
his form of Justice unclear Justice he's
an enigma right now and I think the
mystery will be revealed sooner than
later we also see scenes of Bonnie and
Kuma's surgeries too like for instance
we see Vega Punk changing Kuma's
shoulders finally after 6 months Bonnie
surgeries are over and she's brought to
the sorb kingdom as agreed Connie and
the others welcome her back notably
Connie has a hat that looks the same as
the one Bonnie wore to sabot it's agreed
that Bonnie will live in the church for
another year under the medical team's
care but the medical team is made up of
government agents and their leader is
cp8 Agent Alpha we're told she's a sexy
nurse so we have that to look forward to
on a much more serious note though Kuma
says goodbye to Bonnie and his last
words are thank you for being born
Bonnie end quote and oh God that is so
beautiful and heartwarming and painful
at the same time because we know those
are his last words to her but for Bonnie
she just laughs since she doesn't know
she'll never see Kuma again at least not
the real Kuma with his memories intact I
got to hand it to Oda he really knows
how to hit us in the fields then Kuma
heads out to sea to do his duty as a
newly appointed warlord we get another
Montage of reactions this time to
warlord Kuma news it makes me remember
last chapter where Dragon said he was a
king Tyrant and pirate since they last
met well now he's been a slave Pastor
revolutionary King tyon pirate and
warlord I don't know if anyone has had
more titles than Kuma in this series oh
yeah let's not forget cyborg but what's
most interesting are the reactions we
see we see the reactions of the other
Warlords including mihawk we see Alva
Kobe Dragon Sabo and koala too for his
part doflamingo says Kuma the Tyrant
looks like we have another villain in
the line quite the ironic line when you
think about it Miss all Sunday asks
crocodile if he's interested in the news
and he says doesn't matter did you get
rid of the guy who saw the artificial
rship my favorite though is the next one
at least until we see Luffy again as
we'll get into later we get alv reacting
to the new news about Kuma being warlord
saying supposedly he's a man close in
size to that Whitebeard Kobe who do you
think is stronger mere him and then we
get the old scaredy-cat Kobe saying of
course it's you lady elv end quote this
is one of the reasons this was a great
chapter for the Milestone of
1,100 because by showing us what all
these characters were doing before like
Kobe who had one of the best glops in
the series it shows us how far we've
come and reminds us of just how long
we've been with these characters it's
like a celebration of all of these
characters we've come to know their
evolution and the ones that didn't make
it to the present I mean if you think
about it the manga was first serialized
in 1997 and so it's approaching 27 years
at this point and some people have been
following along since that point and for
those people they must really appreciate
chapters like this that with the
contrast of past and present really make
us feel the time that's passed from
point A to point B and in turn it
definitely makes us more invested in the
character and what will ultimately
happen to them in this story while also
allowing us to finally remember those
that are no longer alive in the story
then after alvita mentions Whitebeard we
fittingly jump to whitebeard's ship Ace
and jimbe are talking about Kuma with
Whitebeard Marco and teach yo crazy to
see Teach now after everything before he
made his move and turned against the
Whitebeard Pirates it makes you wish you
could just step into the panel and warn
all the others of his actual evil plans
but Ace just says jimbe a successor has
been chosen great and Jim B says you're
one to talk Ace I'm reading it right now
a former King we have also a current
king among us too the pirate World Shure
has changed and of course we know
doflamingo was king of just Rosa for a
time as we saw this chapter Ace was the
one who took out the previous warlord so
it's especially fun to see his reaction
here and he's just a fan favorite
character Luffy's older brother so it's
always cool to get more moments of him
even if it has to be through flashback
now let's jump to boa though and she
says this has nothing to do with me
since I will never participate in the
meeting and gloriosa says snake princess
wait even if so you should still have
the knowledge of it Moria for his part
laughs and says apaa human what the hell
kind of power is that and quote another
fun moment not only because that paum
could destroy Moria but also because we
know that both Moria and Kuma will cross
paths and play a role with the straw has
during the Thriller bark Arc you know
the arc where nothing happened we see
Dragon again and being a stoic a few
words he doesn't say anything we just
get a dot dot dot after this insane
Montage we see Kuma is writing a letter
to Bonnie where he said that he's
exploring many islands they can travel
to together one day in the future
moments like this really make me hope
Kuma will regain his memories at some
point otherwise Oda is just twisting the
knife in the emotional wound right now
we then see a younger Luffy running away
from a tiger in a forest like with Kobe
it again serves to show us how far we've
come and specifically how far our
protagonist has come Luffy is laughing
saying it's mad now and at the same time
Kuma ship is also seeing arriving at
fusha Village Luffy's Village he
receives a den den Mushi call the
government agent says Kuma we have an
order from the government for you where
are you right now and Kuma says in the
East blue what's the order let me know
what do you think this Cliffhanger order
will be and is there a big reason Oda
got Kuma and young Luffy so close
together like this right here but if you
did enjoy learning more about strong
characters like Kuma then you won't want
to miss my recent video about Shanks
where he talk about how his true power
and identity have finally been revealed
in the manga link on screen right now
like And subscribe to help us reach our
dream of 2 million subscribers here on
YouTube and I'll see you in the next one